All right, I'm Destin welcome back to Smarter Every Day. This is part 2 in our slow motion sound series
We're recording stuff with the Phantom
And we're going to just play it back and show you how to create those sounds and there's something just inherently funny
About a banana and right next to your face about blow up. I don't know why, but that's just funny! Also something funny about a bana...
Whoa! *hysterical laughter*
All right look this is gonna be one of the more ridiculous videos on smarter every day
It's because Gordon and I got the giggles right so this video is about
Blowing up a banana right next to Gordon and a bottle and showing how the slow motion sounds are created, but if I'm honest
It's more about hanging out with Gordon. Here you go; slow motion sounds.
Gordon: Whenever I'm explaining what we do on the channel to people, I really hold us to a higher standard
than a lot of other channels. Like you know we we do 'edutainment'
We're very educational; sometimes the science gets really deep. We're not like all those other channels that just, like, blow stuff up,
and don't teach you anything.
We're not like them at all. As soon as you bring me here it's like; 'PUT A FIRECRACKER IN A BANANA!'
*laughter*
Science later!
*more laughter*
Okay, yeah, oh man
Oh wait is the audio recording?
What's happening
This is so scary
Is this a dud that's not going to go?  I don't think it's going to go.
That was the most intense, like 30 seconds. I haven't laughed that hard in a really long time.
All right
My heart. Why you do me like that, banana? All right, baby? Yeah
This is why we came to Alabama for
To learn about the culture. Okay
Bang! Bang!  Ohh!  Got it!
Did you get it all over you?
You good? Earplugs work? Yeah, yeah. All right, let's look at the high speed. Gross! Okay,
I know we're goofing around and having a little fun here, but do you remember what Gordon said in the last episode?
We are gonna record the sound because one of the questions we always get is
Can you just record the sounds real-time and slow it down the answer is no, which we'll explain later
We recorded this video at 28,000 frames per second, which is roughly a thousand times slower than standard video.
Here's the slow most sped up a thousand times and laid over the top of the audio exactly as we recorded it
Now let's cut the audio speed in half
Here's audio at a quarter speed. Here's one tenth the speed of the original audio.
Once we stretch the audio down to
1/100th, it no longer sounds like an exploding banana - it sounds like something else I love. Can you figure out why this is happening?
Slow motion banana explosions sound like the Saturn V rockets
No, slow motion sound effects are not recorded at the moment, right? No they're not. And why, why is that?
Because when you slow down a sound you make the waveform longer, you make the sound lower
So we think we can get a more interesting
organic feeling effect by redesigning it.
If Gordon's trying to make this slow-motion video feel more organic and interesting by adding things to it
What kinds of things is he looking for? There's one more experiment,
let's see if we can figure out how he thinks. Okay last thing - do you remember the first video
we worked on together? Sure do. What was it? It was bottles, and yeah, we blew up some bottles
And it wasn't a science video it was more of just like an... art thing?
We used your song, Cicada's Waltz, so, so I think we should blow up a bottle... for old times sake here. Sure, yeah that'll be fun.
So I'm thinking bullet comes in the neck here
in and then we should be able to see the bullet do its thing on the way out,
and everything's gonna get wet. We're gonna hide because there's gonna be glass that flies.
The aim looks like it's the right offset that we figured out earlier. Three, two, one
One of the first things we do always is we always lay down like a drone and just underneath everything, to give like...
To make the silence more interesting, and because there is no such thing as like a totally silent room, other than like an anechoic chamber
We're gonna go bam. We got something for the... we have to do our impact
What's so what's interesting that we want to highlight in this video, I think,
is definitely gonna be the cap launching off, and we're definitely gonna want like sound for the bullet coming through,
and this split here is also one of the more interesting parts of the video.
As well as the exit of the bullet. So you pick out like specific things that happen temporally
and then you highlight them with sound. Yeah, yeah,
because if we just try to cover everything realistically, it can become just sort of like a mishmash and...
Or just like a wash. We just we're picking the important parts, and we're highlighting those things.
That's what keeps entertainment interesting. It makes sense now that I think back on the slow-mo footage you've done in the past.
Yeah.
You look for like knocks or bings or something that's hitting. What do we want people to look at,
or what is, what are people already looking at. So you're highlighting visual things with acoustic cues (yeah), or audio cues, that's awesome. Yeah totally.
What can people do right now with their mouse to support you in a way that changes your life for the good?
Follow me on Spotify. That would be handy
A Shell In The Pit on Spotify. And just follow you. Yep, you can listen to all the smarter every day music there,
and all my game soundtracks. That's awesome. Yeah. Thank you very much dude.
All right, I know this video was different, um, but I hope you understand now that
slow motion sound is in fact created by a guy named Gordon McGladdery from A Shell In The Pit, but I want to say
thank you to the sponsor because that helps me pay Gordon. This episode of smarter every day
was sponsored by
23 and Me
The sponsor for this video is
23 and Me which is a personalized genetic testing service - if you want to check out your DNA all you have to do is go to
www.23andme.com/smarter
And you can get a kit, just like this. This kit will come to your house, you spit in the kit
and then you mail the kit off, and once you do that, you get to learn a lot of stuff about your own DNA
It's fantastic
I went and checked out the lab itself because a lot of people are concerned about privacy
But I went and checked out exactly how they did everything, for example, this is a genotype test. They're not testing every specific
location on your DNA - that would be sequencing.
This is a genotype type test so it's not your whole genome. Anyway
If you want to know more about your own body then go to 23andme.com/smarter
and you can get your own DNA tested, and you can learn all kinds of different stuff
I enjoyed it because I got to talk about the results of where our ancestors were from with my father
Which was a blast. Anyway, if you support Smarter Every Day by going to 23andme.com/smarter
That will support me, which enables me to continue to support Gordon,
which means we've got plenty of slow-motion sound to come.
Anyway, that's it. I'm Destin. You're getting smarter every day. Thank you for tolerating this video
I know this was just more of a fun video than most, but it was uh, it was a blast.
I'm Destin, getting smarter every day. Have a good one. Please consider subscribing if you feel like somehow this has earned your subscription. Bye!